foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
I think it's
so it must be true if
[Music]
my question
I don't I only have one
I'm out this whole
president of the United States thinks
something
then it must be it's an order it's a
goddamn order I I've only got one
question about this
so if the president United States and we
see the bonehead behind me here if the
president United States
just gets to think something and that is
what becomes reality
I wonder if Joe Biden
I wonder if Joe Biden when as soon as he
was sworn in being president of the
United States like the moment I mean the
second he was sworn in
as president United States if he thought
you know all the documents all the
documents that the former guy that
Donald Trump
had Declassified they're now classified
again same classification what if he
thought that I mean it is possible I
mean think about it if if we're gonna go
by the rules here and the rules are that
as long as the president thinks
something then it must be true
then Joe Biden just thought that while
he was being sworn in as soon as he
lowered his hand took his hand off the
Bible he was the president United States
in that moment he thought you know what
all those documents that Trump
Declassified
classified
this is really [ __ ] stupid folks this
is really dumb this is not how it works
at all not even [ __ ] close he [ __ ]
knows it they [ __ ] know it it's dumb
it's stupid it's stupid as [ __ ] I've
ever seen in my life that Sean Hannity
didn't go this is not how this works
that's not even closed how it works that
[ __ ] sycophant Sean Hanny what a
[ __ ] joke what a [ __ ] joke
that we have right now in our country
best part about the interview
is do this question
about
four different criminal investigations
like John Hannity last week
he makes a list of crimes that Trump's
being investigated for and just Scrolls
them on the screen on Fox News like Yep
this is all the crime that he's done
this is all the grind that he's being
investigated for because he's a [ __ ]
Criminal
and and when John Andy interviews him
he's got to ask him about all the crime
he can't ask him about anything else
because that's all this guy does is he's
a [ __ ] Criminal
oh [ __ ] I I just this is uh
you know everyone wanted Trump painted
into a corner and really he talked his
way into a corner here
and this Declassified classified [ __ ]
the only reason why he's in the position
that he's in is because of himself he's
his own [ __ ] worst enemy and that's
the best thing we got going for us right
now is that really any of these trumpers
any of them
I'm not just talking about him but any
of these trumpers
they are Their Own Worst Enemy I mean
this morning Fox News is trying to make
a statement that Stacy Abrams said into
a q Anon conspiracy theory like okay
well even if even if
Casey Abrams is queuing on and that's a
bad thing where the [ __ ] have you guys
been in the last four years
on this Q Anon stuff where the [ __ ] have
you been you've been spewing this q and
on a conspiracy theory on every single
one of your [ __ ] Prime Time Shows
and now all of a sudden Stacey Abrams
says something about ultrasound machines
and it's a q Anon conspiracy theory I'm
not [ __ ] you I'm gonna show you the
clip you know we do not look away here
we lean into democracy folks and the
only way to lean in is to know what
these [ __ ] are saying
even even Grandpa Poopypants himself
you gotta you gotta know what the [ __ ]
they're saying so you know what the hell
they're gonna do
and they're telling he's saying he's
saying [ __ ] out loud like he's telling
us out loud hey the documents that I
stole they weren't Declassified because
that ain't how it works
and also the reason why I took them is
because it has to do with me and my
collusion with Russia I've been telling
you this I've been saying this since
they [ __ ] went down to Mar-A-Lago and
we found out they raided him and took
our documents back
I've been telling you the reason why he
had them isn't because he thought these
were good documents to have they have
his [ __ ] name on him
the documents that are in question here
that he broke the law he committed crime
and stealing top secret classified
documents
the reason why he took those documents
is because a lot of them have his
[ __ ] name on him
100 percent full stop that is what these
are he was trying to steal the
intelligence that was on him
from the government
he wanted to steal it and take it away
so we didn't know that [ __ ] about him
and I'm sure he took blackmail you know
he's mentioning Hillary Clinton emails
and all this nonsense look
there there are no Hillary Clinton
emails there is no Hunter Biden lamped
up all that [ __ ] is [ __ ] [ __ ] and
you know it's [ __ ] because they keep
saying it
they keep saying it they keep talking
about it it's [ __ ] nonsense it's
absolute nonsense there has been nothing
produced not a single [ __ ] iota
of evidence anywhere
that Hillary Clinton somehow had
classified information on a private
server and even if she did even if she
did
she must have thought she didn't which
in in in our world now the standard is
as long as you think it it must be truth
it's really [ __ ] dumb it's really
stupid and the best part is is this is
not going to be a any kind of legal
argument for him his legal team his his
[ __ ] allies here who who colluded
with him
and conspired with him to steal these
[ __ ] documents and then to hide these
documents and then to hide the fact that
they weren't giving all the documents
back when they said they did they're
[ __ ] they are [ __ ] here and you know
they're [ __ ] because he's on Sean
Hannity jacking his jaw did you see this
this [ __ ] can't stop jacking his
jaw
that's what he's doing he's [ __ ] he's
completely pissed here that that we
found out who the [ __ ] he is
and then and then yesterday
when the Attorney General of New York
dunks that [ __ ] in the trash him
and his [ __ ] criminal family do
he gets even more pissed because his
laundry machine is money laundering
machine
is about to get smashed up with a
[ __ ] Hammer by the attorney general
in the state of New York
all the while you have Genie Thomas
making a deal
with the January 6 select committee
which is only an indication that Jeannie
Thomas knows she has criminal liability
here no [ __ ] question why do you
think all these [ __ ] went in
and talk to the January 6th select
committee to try to absolve themselves
of legal [ __ ]
liability
they sang
like like [ __ ] canaries
a lot of them
Rona McDaniel Stephen Miller Bill Barr
the ones that pled the fifth
are the ones that are really already
[ __ ]
just like just like in the [ __ ] Trump
organization case in New York the civil
and the criminal case because there's
two cases two of them there's a criminal
case and a civil case now there's a
civil lawsuit and a criminal indictment
against the Trump organization whether
you want to believe it or not
in those cases the people who play the
fifth
f-u-c-k Capital [ __ ]
and even the people who didn't bleed the
fifth they're [ __ ] too
really only one that seems to be coming
gonna come out of this like a shiny
smelling Rose is Ivanka
you know Jared he's a evil vile piece of
trash
weirdo [ __ ] weirdo
he looks like some kind of you know
Android or or humanoid or some [ __ ]
right like a robot with a human skin I'm
just saying here's the thing is I think
Jared's smart enough to know that the
Trump organization was a criminal
organization he's a criminal so he knows
I mean it takes one to know one so he
knows he knows that the Trump
organization is a criminal organization
and my guess is he was smart enough not
to have anything to do with the Trump
organization I mean other than he
married
Ivanka
but in a federal criminal trial the feds
can't force the spouses to testify
against each other there's protections
there
they can't so
so as long as Jared stayed separate from
the Trump organization which it seems he
did because
Jared kushner's name was not on that
list it seems that Ivanka may still have
a stash of criminal money like Saudi
criminal money
right so I mean even if she gets banged
up by this Trump organization thing
she's still gonna be able to run around
act like she's rich
that's not the only criminal case they
were talking about
him and Hannity
I I mean it doesn't stop it doesn't stop
oh they're they're people are mean
they're taking advantage of me they're
oh I'm the victim blah blah blah blah
blah
try not to steal our [ __ ] election
try not to steal our classified [ __ ]
documents try not to steal tax dollars
from the people of the state of New York
try not doing that and then we'll we'll
talk about you being a victim you little
crybaby [ __ ]
this is all ridiculous
all of it
and it's all gonna come crashing down on
them
because they he's their [ __ ] Jesus
this morning everyone's talking about
Stacy Abrams
Stacy Abrams makes a statement on stage
Q Anon all of a sudden
and I don't understand how what she said
has anything to do with kiwanon
but if Q Anon bad holy [ __ ] you people
are in real trouble
Stacey Abrams has one thing on stage
and she's queuing on and she's gonna
lose because there's a poll get the [ __ ]
out of here with that nonsense the media
sucks at this they are [ __ ] horrible
at this at this point number one the
polls are Antiquated they ain't
computing
just look at New York's 19th look at
Alaska look at Kansas they're not
they're not [ __ ] computing
they're Antiquated something's wrong
with the polls
don't believe them folks do not believe
the polls and only the only reason why
to believe the polls is if it motivates
you to go vote
and to engage in the voting process in
your democracy that's the only way you
should listen to these [ __ ]
if Stacey Abrams coming down in the
polls motivates you to engage your
democracy fine great let's do that
whatever however you got to use this to
motivate you and your [ __ ] community
to get this done
we got to get out in front of these
[ __ ]
if Stacey Abrams isn't the governor of
Georgia you don't think the governor of
Georgia or may use their power or
someone may be able to coerce them to
use their power to squash investigations
in certain counties [ __ ] out of here
with that nonsense these people are not
about above committing [ __ ] election
crime
or getting rid of [ __ ] investigations
for that matter Bill Barr
so
you got to stay vigilant now we're going
to watch the Stacey Abrams tape but
we're gonna watch Fox news's take on
this how she's down queuing on Stacy
Abrams is curing on [ __ ] out of here
this
we live in such a [ __ ] Twilight Zone
we are two months away from this
election
November row row row your vote folks
it is super important that you stay on
task here
and you know exactly what the [ __ ]
threat is
and the threat isn't Stacy Abrams saying
something on stage about a goddamn
ultrasound machine
here's it right behind me see here
they're talking about this poll look at
the [ __ ] media this morning right
behind me here on CBS News oh boy I got
the pole the pole says oh my God States
Amber see
shut the [ __ ] up with the poles No One
Believes this nonsense anymore
and if you do believe the nonsense
you're believing just a bunch of [ __ ]
dribble
we know that now with Kansas and New
York's 19th in Alaska be confident be
confident in your democracy be confident
that we're gonna pull this through
because if we're not confident we will
[ __ ] lose
and it's not just losing the house it's
not just losing Governor's races
it's not just losing Senate Races by God
we're gonna lose our [ __ ] democracy
your way of life your the [ __ ]
schools you send your kids to they want
to shut them down hell Ron DeSantis is
is Banning Book Fairs you don't think
that's just the beginning
their human trafficking even Grand
DeSantis the governor of Florida is
human trafficking
Asylum seeking migrants
all the way across the country in Texas
committing fraud against these people to
traffic them by the way
the same thing they want to do
the same thing they want to do
to liberals in other states in their
states you don't think they'll send them
wherever
by God you don't think like this you
don't look like this we'll send you to a
tent camp somewhere
that's the next phase
how do you how do you think 1930s 1940s
Germany went how do you think it went
how do you think it went go watch the
Ken Burns documentary if you need a
little [ __ ] hint
these people are fascists they want to
take your [ __ ] Liberty they want to
take your [ __ ] rights they're at the
door the good news is they're a bunch of
dumb [ __ ]
and they got Captain dumb [ __ ] as their
[ __ ] leader
all you have to do is lean into
democracy
just lean into it a bit
and fight for it do the things that
democracies do which is engage
that will solve the [ __ ] problem
trust me I know it I know it doesn't
sound like it oh Tony they're trying to
take our vote everywhere we'll crawl
over hot [ __ ] clothes and broken
glass to go vote and to register and to
register people to vote registrations
are up
among by the way
among demographics that are not going to
vote for trumpism they're going to vote
against trumpism and that's what we have
to do folks we have to a vote against
this nonsense
we have to vote for pro-democracy
candidates who are interested
in our form of government and our
constitution
and the rule of law
this simple rule of law you think it and
it must be true
listen if anyone else was under
investigation former president whatever
I don't give a [ __ ] who it was
a government official
David Petraeus is a good example
they wouldn't go on Fox News
and tell a bunch of lies to try to cover
their criminal tracks because it ain't
gonna work it won't work
if you need any more proof that it won't
work just look at the 11th circuit
slam dunking judge Cannon
it's not gonna [ __ ] work look at
Deary slam dunking the Trump the Trump
team trying to get a special master so
that he can save himself or some [ __ ] I
don't know what the [ __ ] he thought a
special master was gonna do
all he had to do was listen to a couple
legal Scholars out there and go well
that ain't a good idea
and it wasn't a good idea
if someone anyone else did what he did
which is steal a bunch of
top secret classified documents and then
after it's found out he stole them
wouldn't give him back and he obstructed
and he still has them we're gonna watch
the [ __ ] we're gonna watch clips of
this today folks
it is super important that we know who
this [ __ ] is and what he's doing
and the reason why is because camp camp
in Georgia who's running ins Abrams
he'll let him off the hook
he'll let him off the hook if we give
them the house if we give them the House
of Representatives
off the hook he'll go off the hook he'll
go
if you elect Ron DeSantis in Florida
anything Ron DeSantis can do to get him
off the hook he'll get him off the hook
this guy is a crybaby little [ __ ]
and his little sycophants
in his America First Nazi party are
willing to do anything for the fear her
for the orange Jesus
they'll go to any [ __ ] length here
just doubt me
just doubt me I'm telling you
I'm telling you those documents he stole
now I don't have any other proof than
what he said
and he's saying it out loud
they have to do with him
the [ __ ] he stole from us from our
government he's TR he stole it because
it's got his [ __ ] name on it it's the
intelligence that our intelligence
agencies collected on him
that's why he took it I mean amongst
other things
but the [ __ ] he's terrified of the most
is the intelligence they have
on him
just doubt me
hell go buy the [ __ ] t-shirt if you
want
we got him over at
store.dtonymichaels.com
you can buy a sticker coffee mug or a
hoodie
but I'm telling you just just doubt me
just doubt me
that's exactly what's in these
[ __ ]
and I don't need any more proof other
than he's saying it out loud because
he's saying yeah he's saying the
opposite right he's projecting maybe
maybe you just get Hillary's emails and
maybe maybe it's uh Russia collusion
Russia Russia objection
how much you want to bet
how much you want to bet there's
evidence of a p tape
inside these these Declassified
documents
as if it even matters it didn't even
matter if they're Declassified or not
which is the the craziest [ __ ] thing
that's what Dairy the point dear he's
trying to make it doesn't [ __ ] matter
doesn't matter classified Declassified
you can't prove you can't even prove
that they're Declassified they said they
could prove it then he goes on hand and
he show and says why I didn't do
anything I just thunk it I just thunk it
and it's true there's your evidence they
didn't do any process none he didn't
even wave his big man I was giving him
credit I've been giving him credit these
last weeks
by saying he waved his Big Mac stained
hands over these boxes
I mean imagine imagine having a Cheeto
dust seance
right
you got you got a couple buckets of
fried chicken you got two liters of Diet
Coke
and you got you got Big Macs
as far as the eye could see on a buffet
and then you got just Stacks and stacks
and stacks of classified documents in
boxes
and you got the lights turned down low
you got the you got the porn music
playing
and everyone's everyone's chowing down
on Kentucky Fried Chicken and Big Macs
and then the guy walks over and he waves
his hand over the boxes
and he says ye now Declassified I don't
know what he would say
but he's admitting
on television that he didn't even do
that
he just thunk it well [ __ ] thought just
popped in my head so boom they're
Declassified which is not even in the
universe of how it works not even in the
universe like I'm again I'm giving him
credit by saying he's standing over
these boxes with his big mac stained
hands waving his hands sander
Declassified I mean at least that's a
physical action
there's some sort of physical action he
literally is just saying because he
wants them to be Declassified they are
because he's entitled
he's entitled to just think something
and it be true
it's dangerous [ __ ] folks I mean it
sounds funny
it's laughable
at a bare minimum it's laughable
because it's so [ __ ] ridiculous but
it's dangerous as [ __ ]
it's dangerous as [ __ ] to think that the
president of the United States no matter
who the [ __ ] it is no matter who it is
I don't give a [ __ ] who it is
if we go
the route that all a president of the
United States has to do is think
something I mean Jesus Christ we went
through this with his stupid [ __ ]
tweets well I tweeted it so it must be
true I tweeted so it must be our order I
mean do you remember when he tweeted
his bigoted [ __ ] about the lgbtq
community in the military
DOD freaked the [ __ ] out they're like
whoa [ __ ] is this is this is a tweet and
Order
they're like well we're in [ __ ] new
water here
this is dangerous [ __ ] to assume that a
president United States can just think
something just think it
and they can retroactively two years
later said I thought it so therefore it
is it's really [ __ ] dumb
and it's really dangerous territory it's
authoritarian
it's [ __ ] dictorial
it's delusional it's lunacy
and it's dangerous [ __ ] [ __ ] and we
have to head this off folks this is who
they want to be their [ __ ] leader
they want him to be in charge government
they want him to lead their party
into the abyss I guess
but this is their plan and they're a
bunch of [ __ ] sycophants and they
know he's a dumb [ __ ] they know he's a
lunatic there's no way they don't know
this there's no way any person with a
half a half a [ __ ] brain cell watch
that interview with Donald Trump and
Sean Hannity and realize he is a stupid
[ __ ]
and he shouldn't he shouldn't even be
near near our government not even close
to it
I don't even think he should be
endorsing candidates at this point
that's how [ __ ] dangerous this [ __ ]
is but we don't get a choice in
democracy there's Freedom there's
liberty that's the beauty of it
but you have to engage in it
to make it beautiful otherwise they'll
bastardize it
they'll make it ugly as [ __ ] they will
I'm telling you
you just look at your history of
1930-1940s Germany they will take
advantage of this [ __ ] they're trying
they're they're damnedest
they're trying their damnedest and we
can't let them get away with it we can't
we cannot and you definitely cannot
listen to the [ __ ] polls or the
[ __ ] media they are so [ __ ] full
of [ __ ] they're not the enemy they're
just full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're not the enemy they're just full
of [ __ ] because they want profit
so don't be don't be too concerned with
the polls unless it scares you to go
vote then believe them
I'm telling you whatever you got to do
to motivate you in your community to
realize what's at stake here
because it's just not the dumb orange
mango Mussolini Jesus
that could be speaker of the house which
is a place of [ __ ] ability that is
their plan
in some corners of the America First
Nazi party that's their plan why do you
think Margaret Taylor green is marching
around the country with him
they're gonna make her a chair of the
committee
Jim Jordan Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan that guy is going to be a chair
of the commit a committee they likely
will put Matt gatz if he wins and they
get the house in a chair of a committee
are you listening to what the [ __ ] I'm
telling you
we're in a situation here
where they're willing
to go down the road is stupid it's
fascist it's [ __ ]
but it's weird Twilight Zone dumb
[ __ ]
so don't believe the polls don't [ __ ]
buy too much into the media just engage
in your community engage in your
democracy don't listen to the noise make
your own noise that's what you should do
make your own noise and lean into it
I'll help you every single weekday right
here I know we're banned from YouTube
people are tweeting uh over and over and
over this morning are you off YouTube
what the hell happened why aren't you on
back on YouTube yet we got one more day
on YouTube one more day on the YouTube
suspension we're temporarily banned from
YouTube
we're gonna be back baby we are back I
think tomorrow I don't know I'm really
confused on what time I'm I'm pretty
sure they banned this last Thursday
which a seven day ban should end today
but you know it's really unclear whether
we'll have a show tomorrow or on Monday
so just stay tuned here at Tony Michaels
dot Live support into media Independent
Media if you can really honestly there's
there's a tip jar right here on Tony
Michaels dot live you can give a
one-time tip or you can do a monthly tip
where it automatically does it five
dollars ten dollars fifteen anything is
appreciated because it keeps us it keeps
us going
even though we're even though we're
temporarily banned from YouTube
it really does any any kind of support
at all not just monetary support when
you guys come here and you're chatting
and you're and you're communicating with
each other in these in the chat boards
right you're on Twitch you're on
Facebook or when we're back on YouTube
and you guys are chatting with each
other it's important
that's important you're engaging you're
making your own noise you're leaning
into it it's really important
so don't just don't I mean you hey again
any monetary support helps us it helps
keep us going helps me keep yelling into
this microphone two hours every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
soon to be back on YouTube on Twitter
twitch and and Facebook and while you're
on Facebook you can follow our page over
on Facebook too and really just go to
tonymichaels.live you can click the
little sandwich icon at the top it says
links follow Tony follow us and go there
and you can follow us on all platforms
Instagram Tick Tock where wherever you
have your social media platforms you can
do that we even opened up a Discord now
we're going to start promoting the
Discord here soon we're going to
broadcast from the Discord as well
it's just something we're gonna do I
want to broadcast everywhere I possibly
can I want to reach as many people as I
possibly can because we have to give
sunlight it is the best disinfectant and
we cannot let up we cannot be scared
people are scared of the f word and oh
they're scared of they're scared of
they're scared of you Tony because you
say it a certain way [ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em we are going to do this
together
and it's not just this this midterm this
is the most important election of our
democracy's lifetime is this next
election this midterm in less than two
months
we're this close this close as soon as
that election's over and we have won and
we have dumped a mountain
of votes on these [ __ ] it's the
next election that is the most important
one because they are not going to stop
they're not gonna quit they're gonna
fight for their criminal lives here
so we have to keep fighting for our
democracy if we want to keep it so go to
tonymichaels.live watch us every single
weekday support Independent Media give
if you can share like send this show to
a family member a friend a colleague
hell send it to your Trump Uncle Uncle
Earl who's a Trumper
hell we got fake Gabe here we got all
kinds of trumpers here that chime in
every single day and vitamin and vitamin
let's have a conversation everyone stick
around we're gonna surf the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends I got a lot of
video I got a shitload of video of
course to get to today because of this
Sean Hannity interview but I also want
to get to some of the Stacy Abrams clips
and how States Abrams is now coming on
they're a bunch of dumb [ __ ] don't go
anywhere and stick around we'll be right
back right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around through the break
yeah a lot of video to get to today we
got a surf the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends thanks for sticking with us this
week it's been a long week with this
YouTube band everyone's tweeting over
about it the YouTube band that we have
going on it's been a seven day
suspension temporary band we can't post
over there I can comment that's about
the only thing I can do I think I think
I figured that out I can't even add a
video to a playlist
I can comment when you comment
underneath the video that's all I can do
that's it over on YouTube but we get our
power back from YouTube here very soon
and we've been trying to appeal all week
we've redone appeals and redone appeals
and refiled and whatever the hell you
call it
and we had had no luck and we're kind of
at the end of it now so what the hell is
the difference
but we appreciate all the support
everyone coming trying to find us
there's been a lot of people confused
like where the [ __ ] are you on YouTube
what the hell happened did you quit no
no not gonna quit not gonna quit not
gonna stop yelling into this microphone
it's very important I've changed my
scenery but I'm not gonna quit
it's not going to happen
I'm here to fight I'm here to lean in
just like I hope you are here to lean in
as well
because it is super important so stay
tuned Tony Michaels dot Live support
Independent Media
support us
now if you want there's a tip jar right
there on the page right next to the
broadcast
just go to tonymichaels.live you can
give a one-time tip or you can tip
monthly
it keeps us going we really appreciate
any support you can give and it's not
just monetary support we appreciate all
support when you guys come here and you
guys chat and you're talking to each
other and you're talking to us
that's that's the that's the most
important part about this whole thing
that's engaging
you should be engaging like that in real
life too just like you do in the chat
absolutely when I'm going after fake
Gabe or someone some other Trump Bumper
in the [ __ ] chat
that's that's I'm trying to show you
that's how you treat your Uncle Earl
you know the one he's got the tattered
chinese-made Trump trump 2020 flag still
on his front porch
got about three strands of threads left
you can't even hardly read the son of
[ __ ] it's so faded
he's got 14 14 different Trump stickers
on his truck they're all halfway peeled
off
he can't figure out if Trump's coming or
going indicted or not indicted can't
figure it out can't figure out that his
his business that he's been running for
decades is not only under civil lawsuit
now in the state of New York but it's
been under criminal indictment
for months
with Alan weisselberg and Alan
weiselberg is about to flip on that
[ __ ] he doesn't he they're
confused they're confused but you have
to set them straight
this is important [ __ ] that we're doing
here
because everything's at stake Jesus
Christ Fox News is calling Stacy Abrams
a Q and honor this morning I'm not
[ __ ] you
over over science
over science Stacey Abrams like yeah
there's no heart valves
you can't really have a heartbeat
without a heart valve really doesn't
beat
at six weeks you dumb [ __ ]
you know what I'm sick of I'm sick of
[ __ ] dudes I'm sick of dudes going on
TV
Talent women what the [ __ ] they should
know and not know about their goddamn
bodies and their pregnancies you stupid
bastards
stop stop if you got a dick stop going
on TV stop
going on TV and telling women what the
[ __ ] the facts are about their bodies
and pregnancy okay it really is not a
good look
it's not a good look it really isn't
you look like a [ __ ] idiot
and that's what happened on Fox news
this morning they literally have a a
woman a female host
who is hosting talking about Stacy
Abrams and the expert they bring in on
Stacy Abram's statements about pregnancy
and a heartbeat and how many weeks they
bring in a man
that's who they bring in is a [ __ ]
man Jesus [ __ ] Christ
and of course the right wing is freaking
out over the Stacey Abrams statement
right
of course it's all nonsense
it's all nonsense because what she's
saying is is is true
there's no there's you can't
have a real heart it's the heartbeat is
not viable the heartbeat does not
signify life dummy
it doesn't no matter what you say no
matter what you do no matter how you
square it no matter what religion you
are whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
because at the end of the day it's not
your [ __ ] business it's not your
business it's the business of that
person who is pregnant and their [ __ ]
doctor that's whose business it is it's
an issue of privacy stay the [ __ ] out of
other people's bodies stay the [ __ ] out
of it
and especially if you're a dude stay the
[ __ ] out of a woman's body
so let's do this because I want to get
to this clip oh my God I want to get to
this clip let's do this let's go to the
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends let's go
surfing [ __ ] start the
countdown
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the show we've reached
the part where we round up all the
Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends in
the [ __ ] list Roundup
boy do I have a lot of video to round up
for you today holy molies okay let's
let's start off with this uh the Stacey
Abrams thing
let's go there first let's go there
first here's the Fox news report I told
you
told you they bring on a [ __ ] a white
dude also crusty ass Tucker Carlson
looking white dude what in the actual
[ __ ]
what what woman on Earth would listen to
this [ __ ] rube
about what she should and shouldn't do
with her goddamn body and her pregnancy
huh are you [ __ ] me
they're actually there's actually women
out there that would listen to this
[ __ ] when they when he tells
them what they're supposed to do
[ __ ] out of here let's let's watch this
this is
Yeah Boy let's go further she says that
it was a made-up situation that it could
happen on an ultrasound at six weeks
made up by men so she's blaming you
wilcane so here's here's the quote
here's the quote Stacey Abram was on
stage at some event okay now they're not
gonna play the video they're not gonna
play the video uh Gabe Sanchez is
joining us Gabe good morning good
morning have you seen have you seen the
Stacey Abrams video where she's talking
about how um there's no heartbeat at six
weeks and even if there is a sound it
doesn't signify life because you can't
really have a viable heart
at six weeks that's just not a thing
that exists it's called um what's that
word science is that the word uh CNS oh
okay I got you maybe I'm mispronouncing
it it's it's an elitist fancy
terms thank you oh so Stacy Abram is
pointing out that on an ultrasound there
is a sound that happens but it's not
actually a heartbeat because you don't
actually like have heart valves I mean
it's not a viable right developed heart
that's creating life it's a clump of
cells that is working its way to being a
heart but it's not there is like
electrical impulses going through this
right that isn't quite all the way
developed yet right and that's what
that's what the sound is I believe and
so so Stacy Abrams says on stage she
says here's the quote and they got it
right they got the quote right here
they're not lying about the quote quote
she says and I'm we're gonna watch the
video but it's really hard to see the
video because it doesn't seem like
there's a really good sound clip out
there of it am I wrong about that I
couldn't find ones I don't know I
haven't even watched the clip yet well I
I couldn't find I'm assuming I'm
assuming that Fox News makes the quote
because without the video there's no
context to the tone well of course Wayne
which is delivered or the question that
was asked I mean right but here's here's
here is the um here's the quote Stacy
Abrams says there is no such thing as a
heartbeat at six weeks which is true
that's a true thing
um it is a manufactured sound designed
to convince people that men have the
right to take control over a woman's
body more truth yeah more [ __ ] truth
because it's men that are standing out
in front of microphones saying we should
have a National Abortion van we should
make sure women don't have the choice to
save their life when it comes to the
pregnancy that's men's saying that right
men are out there also you know that you
bring up a good point which is like yeah
there are women obviously who are pro uh
pro-life that are out there that are
protesting but when it comes to the
actual legislation that is being
introduced or being proposed right or on
it for on on the uh on the ground floor
I don't see a lot of women pushing it I
don't see a lot of women in front of the
microphone I see uh Mitch McConnell
talking about something I see Captain
McCarthy talking about something I see
uh Lindsey Graham talking about
something I'm not seeing I mean like you
know you might have Lauren bobert or
Margaret Taylor green or someone like
that but like
I'm not seeing a lot of women that are
actually like the ones the ones that are
in front of the camera talking about
this issue to say oh yeah we would like
a National Abortion ban I don't know
maybe I'm just not maybe maybe in my
echo chamber I've not seen it well but I
like to think that I see most if not all
news in in regards to what's online on
both sides but I haven't seen a lot of
female lawmakers
in front of a camera pushing this so I
don't know well there has been a few
State female lawmakers who are pro-life
who have went against it because
most most of the time the pro-life
movement for a long time the right to
life movement specifically was always
for the exceptions of rape incest and
the life of the mother there's a reason
for that and the reason why is because
they knew if they targeted women they
would lose a ton of support amongst
what's the demographic
um women oh yeah see see when when you
actually threaten women with with um
[ __ ] that threatens their life they
really start to question your motives
and so there's even Republican pro-life
state legislators or state state office
holders that are standing in front of
microphones going why are you men saying
that we don't get the exception for life
in some of these State bills is what's
happening and these are these are what
you you would deem conservative
religious Christian pro-life women right
are standing up going hey you really
gotta you really gotta check yourself on
this whole exception thing because they
understand the ramifications here and
the ramifications are is this is
politically and electorally this is
really bad for the fascist because now
people know who they are even pro-life
women
pro-life women are going to go vote
against Republicans these America First
Nazis trying to take away their privacy
when it comes to the exception of their
life I mean that think about the
dehumanization that they're doing here
not only with women I mean just at the
Forefront with women but then with with
the migrant situation I mean they really
are proving that they are vile pieces of
[ __ ] yeah and they see no Humanity
anywhere I mean they are
they are not Christians they are
hypocritical you know the the the
hypocritical Republican Christian
[ __ ] like they are not what they
preach right they do not actually
practice the word of God follow uh you
know the path of Christ they don't do
those things because if they really were
then they would say hey let's actually
work on an immigration plan that would
accept people who are looking for uh uh
shelter and that are seeking refuge and
Asylum right which again not illegal not
illegal but trafficking humans and
luring them
pretenses it seems like that could be
that is illegal that seems to leave
across state lines flying them
transporting them from one Governor to
take people from another Governor State
and them in cahoots to send them to a
totally different state to own the libs
like that is all they are to them people
are pawns they're not actually all their
objects they move around the board and
they say you've got these rights you
don't well Gabe Gabe now listen there
are people and it's it's at six weeks
specifically six weeks when you hear
those electrical impulses on that
ultrasound those are humans those are
people right those are people that you
have to protect Gabe they dare right
they care about those are the real
people we need to protect got it okay so
in the womb yeah they only care about
that thing oh it really is man it
doesn't care about that thing no no they
don't fund any organizations or
resources to help a I don't know a
single parent a mother uh no Health Care
no daycare no Head Start nope none of it
none of it well in fact in fact if you
if you actually go out on stage and you
say uh stuff that is provable fact like
there is no actual heartbeat it's not
hey it's not a viable heart it's not a
developed heart at six weeks if you go
out they actually accuse you of being
queuing on so now I'm not I'm not
[ __ ] you here yeah they accuse you
of being a Q and honor if you go which
now is supposed to be a bad thing on Fox
News all of a sudden leaving the
children I don't know all of a sudden
children all of a sudden
on Fox news this morning queuing on Bad
Thing listen
so you you know I'm smiling because I
knew where you're going with this I've
seen the clip in the video you have the
words up on the screen right now where
this is to be clear and I'm gonna I'm
gonna explain what she had to say but
why don't we just characterize it first
this is Q Anon Plus
well I mean you know it's way worse than
Q Anon Gabe yeah I mean q right
this is okay so Fox News has a female
anchor she's a woman uh-huh
and they bring on a Tucker Carlson type
man to come on and explain oh boy and
the first thing he goes to the first
thing is she's queuing on because
liberals think Q Anon is bad I know what
they're trying to do here right they're
trying to do [ __ ] gymnastics here
where they're trying where they're
trying to be like oh you accuse us of
being Q Anon because look at this
conspiracy theory this is not right a
conspiracy theory so so it
uh there's I've got a lot of questions
here but my main one is if Q Plus is bad
it's too fine
like is that what they're saying well
you think it would be like well I don't
know if there's like because there's
dark Brandon I don't know there's dark
chewing on I don't know I'm really
unsure right but when I hear this I see
Q Plus
okay uh interesting title it sounds it
sounds like they got an app now right
right like it's like welcome to Q Plus
here's the Q Anon app Q Plus you get the
cult member benefits oh my God there's a
commercial in there somewhere no I know
you might want to make a note I'm just
saying I will make a note yeah
when you have Q Plus right what they're
saying
because they can't call out Q
they cannot say cute they're saying Q
because what I'm hearing through is like
this kind of uh inference that's
happening is Q Plus is bad Q is fine we
can't talk about Q because people who
watch us might be Associated Affiliated
find themselves in the Q Camp right yeah
but this is more what about ISM don't
you think no no totally it's it's
complete what about ISM but I find this
is the element of
Q Plus is bad but we don't even want to
mention Q right like like q q well I
mean you want it they want it they want
to play footsie with their theories they
just don't want to say it out loud like
they don't want to say that they support
q9 like the Cheeto dust mobster did it
is last Nazi rally where he was doing a
q Anon Seance with the music and the
Nazi the one finger Nazi salute all
kinds of weird [ __ ] so but listen he
does more mansplaining here on this
issue of course the Tucker Carlson type
and I don't know what I forget what this
guy's name is
um I it doesn't really matter just no
it's by the simple no it doesn't matter
let's watch level of conspiracy she says
that ultrasound machines were a
conspiracy made up by men to control
women's bodies that ultrasound machines
that can hear a fetal heart beat at six
weeks are simply a conspiracy she said
that's not what she said that's not what
she said what she said was is that you
[ __ ] like this rube here saying
that the sound that you hear at six
weeks of the electrical impulses that
are starting to happen in the clump of
cells that will eventually develop into
a heart is a heartbeat that is what
she's saying is the [ __ ] you're
using that as the crutch to take away a
woman's right dummy that's what she's
saying that's what she's saying and
there's nowhere now this makes sense why
he said Q Plus right it's because he's
making the argument that this is a
conspiracy exactly life is not actually
that somehow they developed a machine
because he goes on about voting here he
goes on about voting I'm dead serious he
goes into she's an election denier game
I'm dead serious listen listen to this
[ __ ] rube because it's not true you
can't hear a heartbeat and the Machine
is lying to you because the machine has
been designed by men in order to control
women's bodies I want to be clear the
machine and medicine all are in Stacey
Abram's estimation conspiracies against
women and this is someone that you're
supposed to take seriously in a
gubernatorial race for Georgia or I
don't know hasn't she been on the cover
of Time Magazine and been put forward as
a potential presidential candidate at
one point this is who by the way is one
of the biggest election deniers in
American history of the last couple of
years this is the pot calling the kettle
black
whoosh whoosh
holy actual [ __ ] so here is an entire
network who is devoted every day every
single day to propping up the person who
is the actual biggest election denier of
all time all time in our country's
history and this guy has the [ __ ]
balls has the goal I mean this guy's got
some gumption really honestly I mean
this is this is bold this is bold stuff
look I I you know Tony and I don't claim
to be doctors nope not one we do
understand just some basic some basic
science okay and is that like salsa is
that a yeah
damn I I know me some sense I learned it
in high schools well it's not can't be
confused with Seance it's oh well right
anyway the Seance is the thing you do to
declassify doctor yeah okay that's good
non-actual science right okay gotcha but
when you've got a guy that has no
medical degree I saw someone in a shot
that said he previously came from ESPN
you know whatever uh and he this guy
supposedly this guy wait wait this guy
is a sports guy and he's and he said I
don't know
that makes sense totally makes sense
totally makes sense but if I wouldn't be
surprised no well you've got a guy up
here that is mansplaining to a female
co-anchor about how
the science
of a heartbeat in that it exists but it
doesn't really exist at that time I mean
we see the same thing with all of these
pro-life organizations where they take a
photo they do one of those illustrations
that are very uh realistic and drawing
to say this is what a baby looks like
at at like five six weeks but really
that's at like 12 13 weeks they're like
so they're lying in terms of the actual
development of a baby or a fetus at that
time so
this is just another example of somebody
saying one thing when it's not actually
true right you're misguiding misleading
intentionally your viewers and trying to
say oh because
she's actually looking at this and say
like oh they're electrical impulses like
even before seeing this I knew exactly
what was going on right right like I
came in I was like Oh you mean
electrical impulses because there is no
actual heart there is no actual the
heart is a muscle that is pumping blood
and it doesn't have enough and it isn't
developed fully to actually do that
right
um well I I mean the other thing too is
just the words ultrasound just that just
if if someone actually understood the
technology even they would understand
that Stacey Abrams because I'm gonna
show the clip here yeah I got the clip
up here oh her actually saying it now
recount clipped it out and they gave no
context of course and because you know
why would you give context of what she's
saying but anyways you know that's
neither here nor there because what
she's saying is not what they're saying
they're this [ __ ] rube this
sportscaster or whoever the [ __ ] he is
is making it out to be that Stacy Abrams
is saying that the there's a conspiracy
to develop these machines to have a
sound that is made on the the the the
the the machine that's called an
ultrasound like I don't I can't even I
can't even [ __ ] tell you how
ridiculous this is that people don't
even know what the words ultra sound
mean it means it's sending a sound that
you can't hear down into the body and it
reflects back what is being shown that's
what develops a picture and by the way
when it does that it also picks up
electrical connections like you're
saying and sounds that's why it goes
because it makes all kinds of sounds
outside the heart beat that you're
saying is a heartbeat yeah you you
[ __ ] boneheads just you absolutely
you absolutely will believe anything
anything that really stupid people will
tell you to to back up your dumb ass
stupid beliefs where you want to tell
women what the [ __ ] did to do and what
not to do and that's what Stacy Abrams
is saying listen that's what she's
saying you people make up all kinds of
crazy ass [ __ ] to tell us what we can
and can't do with our [ __ ] bodies and
she's right listen to this clip
[Music]
so they got the quote right they got the
quote right but they got the analysis
wrong and it's not surprising on Fox
news that that that dumb [ __ ] has no
[ __ ] clue
uh previously came from ESPN the will
Kane Show on brilliant radio oh I don't
even know if he was on TV he's on ESPN
Radio anyway but will Kane over here is
yeah I mean one taken out of context two
trying to
create
a new interpretation of what she said
which was the heartbeat isn't there
these are like right impulses that the
ultrasound I mean like [ __ ] man the
ultrasound machine I've used ultrasound
to to work on Scar Tissue right down
like this isn't right like I don't I
don't go to the I don't go to a sports
therapist and they hit me up and they go
oh we send some babies heartbeat in here
like that's not how that works well
because because that it just it floors
me that even the machine the machine is
called Ultra
sound like yeah yeah I just I can't even
I can't even we put Maga between Ultra
magazound right that may be what I don't
like it right yeah Rebrand it Rebrand it
a bit I mean it really it really does
come down to the fact that at the end of
the day regardless of how you want to
argue this position Republicans are not
actually pro-life and I see fake Gabe in
the comments
and here's the thing
if Republicans and this is a basic
question if someone can answer this
question please then we can solve this
age-old issue if Republicans really were
pro-life and caring about the life of a
child which which they say protect the
kid and we want to save the children all
that [ __ ]
then why are there no programs
for when a children when a child is born
why are there no programs the resources
are funding that go to a parent why are
they trying to defund and take away the
resources and funding of Planned
Parenthood even if you said Planned
Parenthood could not have abortions
you still as a Republican
try to remove any sort of funding and
resources that would provide the help
that is needed for a young parent
someone who doesn't have access to those
things someone who needs just an a
helping hand if you can tell me fake
Gabe or anyone else who's a republican
in the comments why Republicans claim to
be pro-life yet take away every single
bit of access or care that somebody
would get once a baby's born
just explain it to me well it's a very
simple question if they are this then
they should have access even if you take
away the abortion stuff even if you take
away that stuff tell me
why the funding and resources are
Stripped Away by the Republican Party
well I know I have a really long
explanation for this now my explanation
would never
would never be able to compare to George
Carlin's explanation to this because he
did a masterful job of explaining why
they are they are so hell-bent on taking
away women's rights to abortion and has
nothing to do with the children or what
they claim to be humans that that the
electrical impulses that are happening
inside the body at six weeks and the
ultrasound machine can pick up the sound
that those electrical impulses are
making Jesus [ __ ] Christ
but here's the thing and men are using
what Stacy stadium is saying men are
using that fact to [ __ ] pass laws to
take away women's right but the reason
why is because they're anti-woman
they're anti-woman that's it full stop
that's the answer I mean again there is
a great George Carlin bit out there and
I've retweeted it a million times
um and you can go watch it it's very
simple to find maybe I'll put it at the
top of my page today but it does a very
good job at explaining of explaining
exactly why they want to take away
women's rights it's because they're
anti-woman that's that's the facts do
you want to know do you want to know
what fake Gabe's answer was oh what oh
but oh my God I I I'm dying I'm dying to
know what do you say fake Gabe instead
of telling me about resources and
funding and programs to help my mother
out yeah he immediately resorted to
saying there's a foster care program in
the United States yeah okay so that
makes he said the federal Foster Care
Program pays a portion of state's cost
to provide care for children okay fine
that's a foster care program
but what about giving the mother
the aid and resources to have the baby
right yeah you want to force her to have
it you want to force her to have it
right we should force you to pay for it
see here's the thing here's the thing is
that these are the same people who work
because we under Joe Biden and the
Democrats the entire nation every single
Public School paid for all the school
lunches all of them all of them they fed
the children save the children save this
the children this children that pro-life
pro-life pro-life pro-life well you
can't live without eating and the
Democrats deliver it you know took it
away you knew didn't want to do that you
know who the [ __ ] Republicans [ __ ]
Republicans oh by the way they're
[ __ ] trafficking little kids and
their families all across the country
because they're from a different place
and they want to come here for a better
life under the Asylum uh seeking Clause
that allows them to come here legally so
enough of the spare me with the pro-life
[ __ ] okay so I I want to stay on
this topic but we really gotta go to
this this Hannity interview Gabe this oh
man
like what yesterday after the uh tis
James uh press conference I was like
there's we're gonna have to talk about
this tomorrow again and I'm like
I didn't see this hand of the interview
coming I really didn't see it coming
like every day it's just another [ __ ]
[ __ ] show it's another clown show and
they're only giving us more [ __ ] and
more ammo to lean into democracy and to
win this election I mean it really is
something else I mean I cannot believe
he went on Hannity's show oh I you can't
believe no you can't believe look what
happened was yesterday was a day it was
a there were a ton of things that were
Trump related in the news right right
the first thing was Tish James if I can
dropped the Golem and said 250 million
dollars we're opening uh we're we're
suing you and uh Trump org for the
totally neutered him totally neutered
him boom Lively later on in the day the
11th Circuit Court comes out and says
yeah that frivolous uh ruling by judge
cannon that was dumb as [ __ ] stick it in
your ass Wu The Hundred documents that
are classified that you can review that
was two and then the third one that came
out was Trump doing this interview which
was insane that he said some of the
things that he said
I mean you know we we shared some quotes
back with each other you know I saw some
stuff last night and this morning but
[ __ ] man yeah I mean here I'm not
surprised he did it
uh but I'm surprised that people in his
Camp allowed him to do it well that's
what I I like they I if if I was his
legal team Sean Hannity is a sweetheart
that's what he said at the rally he goes
Sean Hannity he's a sweetheart he loves
his country that's why you know you know
he is a sweetheart because he does us a
favor he he placed a list of all the
crimes he is a sweetheart for that
here's the thing
is if I was on his if I was you know
like anywhere near him really which you
mean proximity or what do you mean like
okay proximity okay I would I would be
trying my damnedest to chain this guy to
the floor to be like you know it's and
it's not a good idea it really is not a
good idea for you to say anything
anywhere like you are totally you're
totally you're totally [ __ ] here
you're totally [ __ ] because we
explained yesterday how he's under
criminal indictment his business is
under criminal indictment but now under
civil a civil lawsuit which is the bar
is much lower in the civil case than it
is the criminal case even and he's
really [ __ ] on the criminal case
because he has his CFO the second in
charge of the Trump organization who is
pled guilty and who has agreed to
cooperate in that deal to [ __ ] charge
and and get a conviction on the Trump
organization and the judges already told
Alan weinselberg if you [ __ ] go back
on this deal you're done buddy I'm just
locking you away bye okay but it's just
crazy to me that Sean Hannity has him on
Fox News and this guy agrees to do this
literally I don't know how long this
interview was in total
but it was all it was all talking about
the crimes that he's committed like what
in the [ __ ] are you doing what are you
doing like literally he he can't talk
about anything else even the wall talk
is about the crime that he's committed
right even the wall talk he's like oh we
couldn't finish the wall and it's too
bad Steve bannon's [ __ ] fraud got got
had we could have built the wall like
what are you what are you doing what are
you doing the wall thing I think is the
funniest part because I actually I
actually dive in and kind of break down
his wall argument yeah cause you're
gonna do what was that on this yeah yeah
and I'm putting the last final touches
and getting the articles but uh in that
I mean well here we'll play the clip and
I'll I'll get here's here's the Wall
clip here's the Wall clip I love the
freeze frames too did you notice in
these clips this guy is like Jack jawed
and he's he's really grinding his jaw
yeah and I'm gonna explain why I think
that is but he's grinding his jaw
especially during these key moments when
he given these key answers
Swatch this [ __ ]
amen they just dismantled that they
wouldn't finish the wall the wall was
completed the original section was
completed I said let's do more we did
more he could have had that finished in
three weeks
everything's two or three weeks with
this guy two-week Healthcare
everything is two weeks out three weeks
out let's let's just lay out the facts
right now under Trump's presidency the
amount of wall that was finished by the
time he left was actually only
80 miles of new wall and that's and
that's the wall that he proposed that is
not not wall that was already designated
to be repaired so there's there's wall
that other presidents uh their their
administrations have put forward and and
done they uh they repaired some of those
walls that needed maintenance but only
80 miles was actually new so it's not
hundreds of miles was built new and they
didn't finish the wall I mean if anyone
geez I can't believe I have to describe
like Topography of like maps and
location but look if you well you got to
Define ultrasounds and how hearts and
electrical signals work look at the
terrain of the Southern border as it
goes through all the states
it's not flat land okay what what you
mean it's not a flat straight line with
perfect concrete to mount a wall on top
of this is [ __ ] ridiculous you'll
never get a you'll never get a [ __ ]
wall up there good [ __ ] lock well you
know you know the other reason why they
don't build walls in a lot of these
places is because even if you build a
wall the not only the topography but the
weather takes the wall out it becomes
irrelevant so the wall doesn't even work
because you can't build one that will
sustain the conditions it's really
stupid [ __ ] and that's part of this wall
so not only not only did they only get
new 80 miles of new wall right the rest
was existing kind of uh helping the the
uh the the the existing wall to repair
maintenance whatever because of some of
the conditions and and a lot of that was
done under Obama it was approved under
Obama to be repaired the other part of
it is that there's over or at least a
quarter billion 250 million dollars
worth of wall that's literally just
sitting out
a pile of rust it is it is unusable they
did not they did not treat it it is it
is [ __ ] over Biden is now you mean he
wasted money come on yeah I know don't
stop giving me facts and now Biden has
to be the one to figure out because he's
Biden's an interesting like he's
obviously repairing walls as they all do
but he's in an interesting position now
where he's got to deal with the walls
that Trump tried to force through now oh
my gosh we should not be surprised here
that Trump uh you know underwent
construction of a wall and he [ __ ] it
over because he either tried to rush it
cut Corners what have you I mean we've
all seen the photos of someone scaling
up all over this wall this impenetrable
powerful uh tall wall that no one will
able to get over turns out people can
actually get over very easily with a
rope or a ladder or what have you wait
wait are you saying are you saying that
that walls are climbable and that if you
have a 20-foot wall you're gonna have
like a 25 foot ladder business on the
other side is that what you're saying
saying all I'm saying come on the walls
can be climbed okay how do you get up on
really tall buildings gate how do you
get how do you how do they get up there
to even construct these walls come on
they fly you well you know there are
ways to go under the wall and over the
wall aren't there but the other the
other thing that you bring up is there
were some conditions like flooding them
okay now in 2020
they warned Trump and they said hey we
actually have to allow these floodgates
to be opened because the amount of force
that comes through like I don't know say
a Summer monsoon in the state of Arizona
would cause damage to those floodgates
like literally and and I'm quoting the
the people that were involved with the
project is this DHA is this DHS telling
him this yeah yeah literally blew the
floodgates off of the hinges
that is what happened wait wait are you
saying that water has enough force in a
flood that that it can damage
infrastructure are you telling me that
that's what happens I'm just saying man
it's almost like
water hydropower in a way it's almost
like there's a conspiracy it's almost
like there's a conspiracy of the water
and they're men taking away the water
rights and actually tearing down the
wall these liberals it's probably it
probably isn't just space lasers maybe
there's space laser Monsoon somewhere
that are causing to knock down a lot it
seems like a big conspiracy very much
like the plot of a like a James Bond
film where someone's trying to control
the weather and I'm almost certain they
had a movie about that but this is one
of those things where it's not only did
they only do less than a hundred so the
claim of we built a hundred miles no you
repaired hundreds of miles but you only
Built new 80 miles two there is over 250
million dollars of wasted steel just
sitting in a pile and three even when
Trump and his team was warned about how
to actually maintain those walls during
weather Seasons they said ah [ __ ] it we
don't want to do it and now because of
that I mean you can go online and
literally search like Arizona wall
damage border wall and you'll see these
photos of like a bunch of debris water
rocks and these [ __ ] just like off the
hinges blown off which means that now
somebody from DHS or whoever has to come
over and repair those things which is an
additional cost but but Gabe if the
floodgates are off the hinges on this
wall and there's no more water there
does that mean does that mean that
someone could get through the wall is
that what that means because it seems
like across the border at that wall that
seems like there would be a spot in the
wall where they could they didn't have
to climb it they wouldn't have to go
under it they could just go right
through it is that is that am I yeah am
I making a weird assumptions like it's
almost like anyone going through those
areas illegally
is because of trump or it's almost like
there's not that wall being there
during a non-blooding season is [ __ ]
worthless and it wasn't worth the money
that we spent to build the [ __ ] wall
and that may be why that may be why DHS
never actually recommended building a
wall there because they knew it would
just be a big pile of I mean there are
sections I've got a friend who went down
to the wall to photograph for an article
he was doing and there was different
points of the wall which they literally
had to stop like we can't because
obviously we go into a mountainous rage
but there's a section where he took a
photo where he's literally standing
between
the the barrier the pylons right there
in the middle so he's got Mexico on one
side and he's got the US on the other
and he's looking down and he's saying
this is the extent this is the furthest
they could go now the distance between
that fence and where the mountainous
range was like another I don't know 30
50 feet pretty wide open Gap right so
when Republicans say oh they finished
the wall and uh they they build hundreds
of miles of wall and it's going to be a
complete border from uh the to to
separate the U.S from Mexico it's all
[ __ ] as well as the fact of when you
say oh Mexico is going to pay for the
wall bull [ __ ] [ __ ] everyone well I
mean unless unless unless you're Joe
Biden then you actually get Mexico to
commit dude it's crazy to repair and
build part of the wall when you when you
go to another world leader and say hey
look why don't we work together there's
some things we can do and it would
actually benefit and then that person
goes oh look collaboration right because
here's the thing is that is that in this
country we can't actually fix what's
happening because what is happening has
nothing to do with the wall right it's
nothing thing to do with who's coming
across or what they do when they get you
that has nothing nothing to do with it
the problem is is we don't have an
immigration policy that is that is
refined enough and and modern enough
that we can actually make sure that
people come here who want to come here
to work as a refugee to seek asylum in a
proper way that is it is easy to do that
process than just than just walking
through the Floodgate that has been
smashed open with water or a big gap in
the wall where they can't build a
[ __ ] wall because it's not feasible
the problem isn't the wall or the
non-existence of the wall or the Border
itself the problem is the legal process
that we have is really [ __ ] stupid to
get someone from one side of the
imaginary line to the other it's so
stupid in fact that it's much easier
it's much easier to just cross over that
imaginary line and take the chance of of
whatever is on the other side of that
whether it be if you can seek Asylum if
that's what you're here to seek if
you're a refugee and you're here to seek
Asylum to go through that legal process
or if you're here for work and you and
you and you just and you cross illegally
for work there's there's also a better
process for that and if we just had
those processes in place I would imagine
that people want to come here for Asylum
who seek Asylum who want to come here
for work they would actually do the
process if it was if it wasn't so
ridiculous and stupid to get here to
work and by the way this is something
I've been thinking about a lot with Ron
DeSantis and Greg Abbott human
trafficking people and we've been
talking about refugees
um and and Asylum Seekers and even
people who come across here illegally to
work
look
the reason why we have a labor shortage
in this country is because the
Republicans are such [ __ ] bigots that
they have stopped migration to this
country for workers we are built our
entire economy's base is built on
migrant workers how in the [ __ ] do you
think you go to the store and buy
chicken yeah how the [ __ ] do you think
you go to the store and buy processed
beef turkey how in the [ __ ] do you think
you go to the store and buy eggs are any
any of the [ __ ] in the produce aisle
where in the [ __ ] do you think who do
you [ __ ] think does the work to get
that to those stores it ain't it ain't
[ __ ] rich white people Gabe it is it
is it is migrant workers who come here
looking for a better life who want to be
a part of our country and they are
willing to do those jobs just to be here
right they don't feel entitled to be
here and by the way someone who's worth
working that hard isn't sucking off the
government being lazy you can't have a
sh the shittiest job on the totem pole
working your ass off to make sure your
dumbass your entitled ass can go to the
[ __ ] grocery store and buy whatever
produce and whatever meat you can buy
process the way you want it processed
if it weren't for people who were hard
working and you goddamn right they
should they should get government
benefits like education and schooling
and have their [ __ ] children be
citizens of this country you pieces of
[ __ ] vile [ __ ] until you understand
these are human beings and they're
coming here to contribute to our country
Patriots Yeah Patriots [ __ ]
they're coming here to contribute to our
economy and our country until we get
over that and we really we really have
elect pro-democracy people across the
board not just in the federal government
but in the states then we can actually
handle immigration policy and that
[ __ ] wall will become irrelevant
it'll become [ __ ] irrelevant we won't
need that [ __ ] wall because
it's useless in the first place it's
[ __ ] useless and in the same way that
I asked the question to those
Republicans and fake Gabe and other
people in the chat that want to say oh
Republicans are actually pro-life you
know if they were pro-life then they
would support women after they had a
child now in the same way that
Republicans say
migrants and anyone who's Hispanic or
comes over the Border or whatever it
might be they're lazy they're not hard
working they're stealing our jobs
just want to point this out [ __ ] you and
also they're not taking your jobs if
they were taking your jobs then you
would have been working those jobs tell
me one person that complains and [ __ ]
and moans about Mexicans or Guatemalans
or Venezuelans or whoever might be
taking these jobs picking lettuce
strawberries working in plants
if they were really taking the jobs then
those people would have been working
them and if those are jobs that you want
you want to complain oh we need jobs we
need to do this then go [ __ ] work
that job stop bitching stop moaning pull
yourself up by your bootstraps because
that's what you love to say and stop
telling that it's it stops saying that
it's these other people these Hispanic
people that are coming over looking for
a better life and pursuing the American
dream and saying that they're the ones
that are lazy they are the ones that
aren't that aren't dying out from heat
exhaustion breaking their backs fighting
for their family to give them money to
send back to whatever country they came
from right or support a new family in
the United States so all of these people
Maga Republicans I want to say Mexicans
are lazier whoever are lazy go [ __ ]
yourself okay
and I say that out of personal bias
because I am Mexican and I have a I have
a father who came across and worked his
[ __ ] ass off to support a family and
give me and myself like myself and my
brother and those and our family in
Mexico a better life
so those people that say we're lazy they
can go [ __ ] themselves because they're
the lazy [ __ ] that won't
[ __ ] get off the couch and actually
do the job that they want to whine and
bitchimon that has been taken away from
them that is the [ __ ] issue here
they're complaining they're bitching
they're moaning but they won't do
anything about it it's easy
to cast a stone and [ __ ] about other
people when you're not doing it yourself
so fake Gabe and the [ __ ] comments
over here and everyone else that wants
to complain about it if you really had
an issue with it you would be working
those jobs I don't know what you do for
your work but you might as well shut the
[ __ ] up because you don't know what
you're talking about here's fake Gaby
says Farm Workers make up one percent of
the workforce hey hey what about what
about construction what about Roofing
how about how how about food industry
how about that dumb [ __ ] how about the
food industry how about Trucking and
distribution you dumb [ __ ] I'm talking
about any [ __ ] job that no one else
wants to do they want to come here and
do it just to be here just to be here
because of the life that Liberty affords
you that is why they're here you stupid
[ __ ] is because what Liberty affords you
and not only that you people are voting
for [ __ ] that are trying to to get
rid of that Liberty which will cause no
one to want to be here no one no one
will want to be here so if you still
want to have a country if you still want
to talk about and and put your hand over
your heart while the national anthem is
sang at your [ __ ] football games
then get off your ass pluck your head
out of it and realize what the hell's
going on that you're being duped you're
being duped dummy Farm Farm Workers make
up one percent of the workforce you're
stupid [ __ ] you are really stupid yeah I
didn't say just Farm Workers I made the
example of the produce and the food in
the store because it's the easiest
example to give you that affects
everyone in this country
you stupid [ __ ] yeah I mean we could
talk about hospitality industry we could
talk about you know the construction the
housing I mean [ __ ] like you know Lane
laying concrete down in a foundation
like the people you mean the [ __ ] you
mean you mean what would be deemed the
shittiest jobs right out there you know
what's funny about this jobs are
unwilling to do but then right things
are being taken again it's [ __ ] that
someone like you know whatever I mean
I'm not it's just upsetting I take it
personally right I take it personally
because when I hear this stuff it's as
if somebody is targeting me and saying
that I'm lazy and I haven't done
anything or my family hasn't done
anything to work their ass off to
provide for our family and support us in
this country for this American dream
that is this illusion really so when
somebody says oh no they're only this
percent or that percent [ __ ] you because
you're belittling and you're
marginalizing us down to a small group
yes we talk about this labor within the
food industry right the the actual
agriculture but there's much more than
that behind the scenes and you see it
every day you go by some [ __ ] Home
Depot
and there's people that are standing
outside asking hey do you need me to
help you move this anything you can
anything you want me to do I'll do it
because I want to live here I I am
desperate for the Liberty that this
country will afford me here's the other
thing
there's a thing in the midwest in rural
areas that and and it's it's really kind
of strange to me it's really [ __ ]
strange this culture
and it's white people culture that they
demean these people they act like uh
they're you know they're rapists and
murderers they don't send their best you
know all the Trump [ __ ] they jump across
the wall they're lazy they take our jobs
even those are two different things yeah
it's really weird because in and and you
can probably attest to this and Rule
America especially in the Midwest
Mexican restaurants have become like the
family restaurant right almost every
Community even really small rural
communities that are really [ __ ]
racist I mean really [ __ ] racist
have a Mexican restaurant where all the
families go to eat and they love the
food they love the food
and what is funny about that is that
they love that restaurant they love the
atmosphere that it delivers they love
the culture that it delivers even though
it's probably not the actual real
Mexican culture it's an American version
of what Mexican culture isn't a Mexican
food is
but here's the thing it's a really
[ __ ] weird thing that they demean
people they they do all this stuff and
then they go and they drink they drink
their Margaritas they eat their Taco
salads and they have fun they they put
the sombrero on when it's their birthday
and they they eat the cake
it's really [ __ ] weird that you
people out there just don't appreciate
human beings in general right but but
fake Gabe in particular demeans people
and acts like Farm Workers
one percent of the workforce is nothing
it's insignificant which only
dehumanizes Farm Workers even more right
you [ __ ] idiot
but you you and your culture to demean
to to mean anyone to demean anyone and
then try to appropriate their culture by
having your nice nice little sit-down
Family Restaurant you know I'll ignore
I'll ignore those Hispanic people that
run that restaurant because Gabe that's
in my community and I go eat there and I
wouldn't want to make sure that on
Tuesdays I couldn't go eat taco salad at
this little this little Cantina that I
like it really is [ __ ] weird to me
I've never understood it I don't get it
like uh when I go it's not it's not just
with that I mean even if you were to
give the example of just like food right
the hospitality food industry you could
say the same thing about anyone who is
like you know uh who has a xenophobia or
right a hatred towards another culture
right loves Chinese food right exactly
Chinese food wants to wants to blame the
virus and the right and covid on you
know uh China but they definitely they
definitely don't want that restaurant to
leave town under that door Dash China
you God damn right that night and they
want it they want it fast too by God
they want and then of course like who's
delivering it could be it could be a
medley of different people but if it's
someone who might be of a different
um you know background color whatever it
might be right you'll you'll accept it
from that person won't you right they
sure as hell well and let me tell you
something else fake Gabe because there's
another industry that you totally
discounted that we didn't mention but I
could go on and on and on here with
construction it's construction's another
industry there's another huge industry
and if you think construction's only one
percent
I I can't help you with anything so it's
not just one industry it's not just Farm
Workers that was an example of what when
you go into the grocery or how you're
entitled ass you're entitled ass gets to
take advantage of Migrant workers hard
work some legal some illegal
the produce that you're picking up at
the grocery store so you don't have to
grow it and you don't have to pick it
and you don't have to have your own
[ __ ] Garden because your the liberty
of America and capitalism has provided
you a way to go down the block to the
local grocery store to the produce
section and just buy it
people who are in this country illegally
who want to come here to work and to
live here and to be part of our country
pick that [ __ ] they worked to put that
[ __ ] on your plate that's the example I
was trying to give you but we can go on
and on about your roof about your
bathroom about the house is built the
concrete on your sidewalk I mean we go
on and on and on and on here about how
migrant workers are an integral part of
our labor and our economy and frankly
the reason why we have Labor issues in
this country is because bigots have been
preventing people to come here to work
migrants to come I mean other than
Mar-A-Lago I mean they definitely want
which also connects to the great
replacement theory that people like
Tucker Carlson and Trump want to push
and then you've got people that are I
don't know uh Mass [ __ ] shooters that
go out and try to solve those problems
that Republicans created and then you
see people like Tucker cross and go well
I I never I never I never said that
stuff I never pushed that idea of the
great replacement Theory no absolutely
not well here's another
uh Aaron posted this video of course and
he says handed he tries to Workshop a
legal defense with Trump like literally
like we're just gonna work through this
I'm gonna say some words you're gonna
say yes no I'm gonna figure out a
defense did they have a conversation
before this thing you think they would
have like two minutes I I can't figure
out how the [ __ ] maybe he has does he
have no one on his team now like no one
honestly I mean like I wonder I wonder
now I mean like he doesn't have I don't
think he has a press secretary outside
of Liz Harrington so I wonder in these
moments does he go I trust Sean Hannity
he's right sweetheart which is what he
said at the rally again and then he goes
I trust whatever you're gonna ask me
because whatever you're asking me is
going to be putting me in a good light
maybe that's maybe they have that
Rapport and he just trusts what he says
and they don't have to like vet any of
these questions well he definitely knows
that Sean Annie's not going to have a
decent follow-up he definitely knows
that for sure because Sean Hannity does
not have anything that sounds great yeah
you know what you're saying sounds like
I want to believe it so that I'm
thinking it and thou thinketh thou Beth
okay let's let's listen to their their
little legal Theory here I told that in
oh Jesus statements oh Jesus even I was
told people are thinking that's the
that's the because it used to be people
are saying now it's going to be people
are thinking that that's the title for
today's shows people are thinking people
are thinking I was told by someone I may
have wrote it down and then read it to
myself I'm not sure people are feeling
right you know people are smelling you
know it's great he's gonna go through
all the senses and he'd be like I guess
all right uh this is just you we all
know it's you you yourself and I are the
many people right that are saying
smelling sensing hearing thinking
thinking thinking surmising right maybe
surmising is illegal right you know well
you're not [ __ ] uh you know Professor
X like you can't read people it's
[ __ ] ridiculous look I'm only four
seconds into this clip that's the
shittiest part here is I'm only four
seconds in let's let's see if we can
make it past 20. well we'll see make it
a loan application and you can confirm
if you know this or not know this do you
put in a caveat that actually says these
are our valuations yeah because I don't
know Lending institution a bank a
financial institution that would lend
money to anybody and just go by the
borrower's estimation evaluation of a
particular property so if you're buying
a 100 million dollar property and you're
putting X Y and Z up for leverage you
estimate its value of this they
estimated at this don't they have a
fiduciary responsibility before you they
give you that amount of money so what
they determine what the value is
especially with these are banks that
have the best law firms in the world the
biggest and best the most powerful they
do their own work they don't rely on us
but what they do is we have a disclaimer
and we put together my people put it
together I would okay so he's going to
push all this off on uh yeah other
people because other people say and
other people do the crime other people
say I didn't commit crime but when there
is crime other people did that I didn't
do it I mean yeah he's at this point
he's
he's backed himself and I think he's
realizing he's backed himself into a
corner so far like back that he's got no
way to go left or right
that he now is like all right well we're
going through the blame game now and
it's guy they're gonna be the lawyers or
the banks or I can't wait to blame my
children right it's gonna be sooner I'm
pretty sure Michael Cohen already
predicted and I haven't watched the
video but he did predict uh which of the
children it's go is going to get uh
thrown under the bus
oh well it seems to be Eric at this
point I mean really I mean maybe an
assumption would be if I were to go on a
list it would be Eric because it's like
this guy's dumb as rocks uh then it
would go down junior and then it would
go uh Tiffany and then it would go Baron
and then it would go Melania and then it
would go Ivanka like that's the family
members he would throw in there I mean
that's the order in there but she's
already passed away so right like well
he had to have a casket to hide some of
these documents and speaking
speaking of the uh the documents and
releasing the documents here they are
here they are um considering thinking
thinking again thinketh and beeth
um about what it would be like to
release the security footage from his
home at Mar-A-Lago this is this is some
weird [ __ ] that we have a former
president United States talking about
this listen they wanted they wouldn't
allow your lawyers to go with them as
they went through this entire they
wouldn't know we sent lawyers to the
property so here's my question but you
they did ask you to turn off your
security cameras that's right but you
didn't do it that's right will you
release those tape
okay so they're talking about security
cameras and they're talking about the uh
the closed circuit TV that is in and on
the Mar-A-Lago compound that caught the
images of this quote-unquote raid which
is the FBI uh executing search warrant
he even says in another clip where they
had AK-47s like the Taliban showed up or
some [ __ ] yeah really [ __ ] weird and
then he says in another clip how all the
FBI agents actually voted for him and
they're being forced to do this by who I
don't know at the FBI the people who
voted for him it's really [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] like this is the people who are out
on the field and executing a search
warrant there isn't any political agenda
regardless of who they voted for they're
just acting out their job right they're
not they're not out there you mean you
mean they take an oath they take an oath
and then they gotta fulfill that Oath by
doing their job come on come on Gabe I
know I know well so this is now uh let
me back it up a bit here where we have
15 seconds so watch his watch him uh
grind his his jaw when he's trying to
answer these ah he's grinding his jaw a
lot of people say it's a methamphetamine
but here's what I say I say the guy is
trying to be really careful because he
you just know just a little bit of spark
would just set this [ __ ] off I
mean just make him go absolutely berserk
and I'm sure like right before they sat
down the one thing Sean handed he
probably said to him was hey don't lose
it don't lose it because we won't be
able to use the footage and we you won't
be able to properly bury yourself
legally here
so let's let's continue watch his jaw
though pay attention to his jaw jacking
around and he's grinding it paid
publicly well they've asked me not to do
it because they feel the FBI agents
might be in physical harm and danger
because
there is a fervor in this country this
country is so tired of this stuff
they're really and so they so I have not
done it you could pixel out their faces
to protect their identity yeah I guess
they could do that I mean look I
listened I said look I don't want I I
really believe that most of the people
within the FBI out of the top groups
most of the people of the epide they
probably voted for Trump I don't want to
have anybody hurt but
so there he's threatening the FBI even
the people who voted for him I guess I
know I can't figure this out like yeah
well I think he's trying to say Guilty
By Association to say if anyone's in the
FBI that you work with somebody that
voted for me or against me like doesn't
really matter collateral damage to
everyone right what's the top what's the
top groups thing what's the top groups
he said top groups kind of top groups at
the FBI right like those like the higher
echelons or something yeah probably is
what I imagine like why is she said why
is he bashing then why is he bashing
Chris Ray oh oh he's saying they didn't
vote for him he's saying the underlings
yeah the underlings oh my God the guy's
holding the AK-47s at the gate those
Jesus Christ this [ __ ] guy okay
um
uh let's see that's the that's the will
one that's not oh this is the one where
he's here's here's the other people are
saying and other people are doing this
is where he blames other people for
packing the boxes here it is hey let me
go through this before you left the
White House
um please explain the process from my
understanding what I've read you have
the GSA they pack all the boxes okay did
you pack it okay so the other day Mike
Lindell had his phone taken in a Hardy's
drive-through and in the interview or
where he was trying to explain he
explains to us how drive through Works
here's Sean Hannity and Donald Trump is
going to explain the American people how
to pack a [ __ ] boxer you [ __ ] me
there's a box there's a box there's the
content that goes in the Box you put it
in the Box well first you got to take
the lid off the Box okay so the lid
comes off first if the box was flat and
then you got to put it together do you
gotta put the box together you might
like I don't know where the picture of
the box like those are those are legal
boxes that you get from like an Office
Depot wait wait are you saying that all
boxes come fully assembled is what
you're saying oh Jesus this is this is
groundbreaking stuff here Gabe this is
ground look I'm no expert but I'm sure
these box aficionados are going to tell
us all about it yeah let's listen any
boxes no they they work together with
people in the white house I don't know
how you would classify him but GSA was
involved that's government services
he doesn't know how he classes I guess
if you just think maybe a classified
well you wouldn't be doing you how to
find them like I know I'm pretty sure
the people who are packing the boxes uh
you know and they probably do know
specifically uh shouldn't take that
shouldn't take that which makes me think
that GSA was kind of like a couple steps
removed from the process well it sounds
like too that because what he's saying
here is that GSA can't just grab like
people from GSA packing up like pictures
because he goes on in this clip about
pictures
um there's thousands thousands of
pictures he says uh just boxes boxes of
pictures but and also some of those
things they are all of those items that
are in the Oval Office and other parts
they're literally a loner that's what
those things are we've got the bust of
Lincoln that's a loner when you go into
the White House and you say how you want
to decorate it you go through basically
a gallery of items and you say I want
that painting I want that bust I want
those curtains I want this here I want
that there
those items are all on loan you don't
own them they aren't yours you don't get
to keep them
it's it's once you're done right they're
ours and then they go right back into
the archives
of where they started and then the next
president to come in they've got their
transition period and they say yeah I I
want that painting and I want that desk
I want this or I want that whatever it
might be right and when you leave office
they take that [ __ ] back where it came
exactly because you don't own it you
were renting it but here he's blaming
he's blaming uh GSA of packing up the
top secret classified documents which
number one the top secret classified
documents shouldn't be in armed reach of
just regular old GSA people packing up
boxes I mean that's one problem that you
have here you [ __ ] twit the other
problem that you have is that you
clearly you clearly are admitting you
clearly are admitting that that you did
put you intentionally made sure that
this [ __ ] went in these boxes right when
he's saying this because it's all but
you forget his personal items like his
passports were on the boxes and he knew
that his passports were missing which
means he knew
that they were put in there whether he
put them in there he instructed someone
to put them in there but he knew where
they were he had the boxes he packed the
boxes like this whole like blaming
someone else for packing the boxes and
putting these classified Declassified
documents in there no it's [ __ ] crazy
let's listen fantastic people and they
packed them and not only that and they
they brought him in along with people in
the white house I don't know who they
are but a lot of there are a lot of
people working in the White House they
packed them up but not that clothing
massive amounts of pictures you know
they take so many pictures every day and
they give you copies of all this stuff
and it's boxes and boxes of pictures
oh my God so here he's claiming that his
boxes and boxes and boxes of pictures
and I Declassified all the pictures all
the pictures they're all because I thunk
it
they Declassified it and and Luanne
actually reminds me of something I don't
know if people heard this it kind of I
feel like it kind of got like swept
under the rug a little bit it happened
earlier this week or late last yeah no
[ __ ] to give Hershman right right
Hershman who obviously is coming around
of a senses uh to uh talk about this
stuff
has given a statement that said he told
Trump not to take these documents he
warned him he said do not do that that
is not good that is illegal you cannot
have them they are not yours
and he still took them again Trump was
warned before he left the White House
that he cannot take these things he was
told after he left the White House that
he should not have these things he was
told after he left the White House while
he was at Mar-A-Lago hey you've got
these documents and we need them back
and then he said on other occasions we
don't have them we gave you everything
we had we don't have any more okay fine
we have some more and we're going to
keep it in the basement oops sorry we
just took some out of the basement
and then he gets mad when uh nara's like
we can't [ __ ] deal with the [ __ ]
anymore doj FBI can you please get this
for us and he gets upset at it and now
you know you know all those things
that's very annoying and it's also like
what dumbass kind of logic are are is
Trump and other people going through to
be like there were plenty of warnings
plenty of signs and you ignore them
every way there's significance in
Hershman uh giving him uh this advice
too because Hershman was part of his
legal counsel in the um White House like
literally this is a guy saying hey what
you're doing is Criminal it doesn't
matter how they're how they're
classified it doesn't matter you're
stealing information that has human
assets on it it you are making it
unsecure which in and of itself is
illegal
um here is uh the clip that everyone's
been waiting for oh my God here's the
eye thunkus so I must have beeth um
clip here it is where he's talking about
he uses his his uh what he would call
his Espionage to declassify this his ESP
you know that's when I you know is right
maybe that's what he thinks Espionage is
do you do are you sure that he didn't
mean ESPN well that might be it ESPN
ESPN his ESP his Espionage yeah to
declassify these things oh [ __ ] this is
yeah right if anyone's listening there's
this Jack jaw there's his Jack jaw right
there
the the the freeze frames for anyone
listening right now should definitely
come over and watch these because uh
just where the clip starts is perfect oh
it's
fantastic let's listen so let me ask you
this question because I I think this is
the next logical question because the
president of the United States you
unlike say Hillary Clinton in her case a
president has the power to declassify
correct okay you have said on Truth
social a number of times you did declare
okay I did is there a process what was
your process to do it doesn't have to be
a process as I understand it
okay there it is there it is there it is
I I'm taking the the the legal defense
of I'm too dumb to know like there isn't
a process that I know of right I mean I
no one told me after that but when I but
then see the dog the dog what happened
was see the reason why the the GSA you
know the people there's a lot of people
in the white okay so I was thinking I
was thinking about this is what he's
saying yeah this is what he's saying
this is ridiculous watch this this is
great this is great American history
footage right here of how [ __ ] stupid
that part of our country has become that
they think this is their great leader
you know there's different people say
different things but as I understand
there doesn't have to be if you're the
president of the United States you can
declassify just by saying um it's
Declassified even by thinking about it
because you
okay so if this is the truth which it is
not it's not even close to the truth
that a president of the United States
can just think that you should
declassify this piece of information
which automatically makes it
Declassified
making it I guess this assumption that
the entire government is going to know
what the president's thinking at any
given moment I guess but here's the
thing if the truth Joe Biden
retroactively could right now say well
here's the thing when I swore in as
president the moment I took my hand off
the Bible and I was now the president
United States I had the thought in my
brain that I wanted to classify classify
all the information that Donald Trump
Declassified because Joe Biden's the
president now then that's the way it
could be and literally Joe Biden could
come out today in front of a microphone
and say that stupid [ __ ] right he could
say that stupid [ __ ] and totally eat
this guy's lunch but Joe Biden's not
gonna do that because Joe Biden isn't
that [ __ ] dumb well yeah I mean like
Joe Biden's like look I don't need to
know how badly
he's doing a perfectly good job on his
own right and I'm not gonna step in and
try to avoid this I'm not going to use
the same logic which is
is is is not even a real thing of this
there's no real process I can declassify
classified as a one but if you really
want to go with that logic yes Biden
could very well say not classified well
but he could even say he could even say
just like Trump is saying here Trump is
literally saying I thought this two
years ago and when I thought it it
became real and now I'm telling you
about this thing that I thought two
years ago being real Joe Biden could do
the same exact thing which he can't
because it's not a thing Joe Biden can't
come in front of a microphone and say
well I reclassified all the information
that Donald Trump Declassified it's not
a thing it's not a thing that the
president can do is just think something
and then it be so that's not how it
works it's not you know the the when I
when I keep hearing this like I think
and therefore it is I just keep going
back to him right holding the skull and
being you know and and that is like
Trump trying to to say that you know uh
it's crazy uh fake gave here he's he's
still in the content we we like fake
Gabe here we like having here buddy you
set him up on the T all the time am I
gonna play the entire quote what are you
talking about what entire quote you only
play the whole [ __ ] interview you
serious do you want me to sit through
that garbage I'm just trying to make
sure that people understand how [ __ ]
stupid you are by supporting this fool
right but also like if we play the full
interview which I don't want to sit
through that there are a ton of Clips
you know ton of clips that are in this
thread that we're going right now
and I'm picking out the ones that are
relevant I'm not sure
not sure Tony
uh one how the the full clip would add
any more to it I don't know clearly
saying I thought about so therefore it
is and it's no big deal and there's no
real process when everyone
who was within a government position or
or has insight into this process goes
nope there is a process most certainly
is a process uh and it definitely
involves the agencies that said this was
classified they need to go through the
approval to say oh yeah you know what we
can declassify it we'll redact this and
redact that and now it can be shown to
the public without fear of revealing
certain Secrets right
um but when you've got things like
nuclear secrets or uh nuclear plans of
locations or whatever like those aren't
things that you can just go about
declassify and just be like um
you can't do it well I mean do it even
Bill Barr even Bill Barr that [ __ ]
vile piece of [ __ ] points out a simple
fact that even if you did Declassified
that doesn't matter that that makes no
difference in the criminal matter but if
that is even more irresponsible than
stealing the [ __ ] right like you're
putting more lives of danger by
declassifying it so everyone can see it
then just stealing it and keeping it in
your desk drawer it's really stupid [ __ ]
and and the last thing is you bring a
build bar which I think is funny because
he goes against Maga right now and he
says oh actually these aren't his
documents he doesn't own these he
couldn't take them he doesn't have any
right to them there is a process then
you've got Maga being like oh no no no
you don't understand you got Mike Davis
that other [ __ ] hack lawyer that goes
on Laura Ingraham and he's like oh Bill
Barr smart guy but doesn't know what
he's talking about so at this point
which was like you know last week and
the week before that you had Maga
Republicans being like Bill Barr doesn't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
then yesterday Bill Barr goes out and
says oh Leticia James overstepped her
reach now he definitely knows what he
said no yeah and now they're like oh
well well now he now he's on ours right
this whole [ __ ] you guys gotta pick a
lane like right you can't like the guy
than not like the guy right especially
when it's coming down to these legal
opinions which in both scenarios Trump
is [ __ ] right right well let's let's
finish the let's finish the clip for
Gabe fake Gabe so he so he doesn't get
butt hurt that I didn't play I guess
that's what he's doing the full clip
let's let's listen just sending it to
Mar-A-Lago or to wherever you're sending
it and it doesn't have to be a process
there can be a process but there doesn't
have to be you're the president you make
that decision so when you send it nope
it's Declassified we I know specified
everything now wait wait did he really
did he think when he gave here's what
I'm concerned about if he was the
president United States and he just
thought I want to declassify everything
does that mean every single piece of
classified information our government is
now Declassified the way that I took
that
I Declassified everything
everything it's like it's it's like that
moment from The Sandlot where he's like
forever this is the moment where he's
like everything
so maybe Trump did declassify everything
in his mind he goes I had this dream and
I Declassified everything right it was
amazing right well that's the other
thing too is is any thought any thought
that a president has is it now have to
become reality so if I don't know it's
let's play the rest of the crib I don't
I don't want to upset
um snowflake uh fake Gabe over here that
we didn't play the whole clip in the
context of stupidity oh by the way he
says Mar-A-Lago or wherever this is only
an indication this is him telling on
himself because his brain is going okay
I have some at Mar-A-Lago I have some at
Bedminster I have some at Trump Tower so
he's telling on himself here because he
probably has some on his he does yet
definitely he definitely ends classified
documents in my back pocket right now
right right we probably he probably
showed handed him when he's like hey
this is the [ __ ] they didn't take look
at this [ __ ] okay let's finish I don't
wanna I don't wanna upset fake Gabe here
classified things and we were having a
lot of problems with Nara you know Nera
uh is a radical left group of people
running that thing and when you send
documents over there I would say there's
a very good chance that a lot of those
documents will never be seen again here
we go
why why all of a sudden is Nara not
narrow why I say Nara Nara why why why
is it all of a sudden a radical
left-wing organization just because the
only reason that the radical left is
because they said hey you actually can't
do what you said you did he knows they
just archive government documents this
isn't like that's what they do I mean
we've talked about this like they are
the you know the top tier Librarians
that are literally holding all of these
documents for past administrations and
agencies to say okay we have to keep
this under under our reserve and we need
to make sure that they're protected and
we need to have a copy just in case
something happens for whatever reason
but we are the masters of these
documents we take care of these things
we make sure they are actually where
they need to be and if they're not then
we need to go find them which is what
they tried to do and Trump and his legal
team said unstructed here under a
signature and an agreement to say we
have given you everything wait you mean
fraud is that what you mean a fraud and
obstruction the lawyers lied so did
Trump and now they're at the find out
portion of stealing classified documents
let me let me let me say something
because I've said this before in the
show I think the best part about this
whole thing about this documents problem
than he's got this this criminal
document problem that he's got where he
where he's under um investigation for
Espionage the best part about this is
he's like Nara is a bunch of left-wing
deep State George Soros what you know
radical leftists
the best part about all this is this
[ __ ] is going to get taken down
by a bunch of librarians yeah holy [ __ ]
this thing about this and no better no
better people than people who adhere to
facts like that's what they deal with is
actual inventory facts where it's at
what it is just just cold hard facts
that's what Librarians deal with on a
daily basis yeah and information and
data this guy's gonna get taken down by
Librarians that's fantastic let's finish
the clip but we got a few seconds left
here I wouldn't want anyone to get their
feelings hurt there's also a lot of
speculation because of what they did the
severity coming in rating while ago were
they looking for the Hillary Clinton
emails
were they looking for the spines
okay so fake game I don't know why you
wanted me to play the rest of this clip
it just gets worse and worse and worse
it's getting worse it really isn't I
mean like the argument of we should play
the full clip for contracts he keeps
[ __ ] digging his graveyard what I
think what he's saying and we're going
to be over time here but I think what
he's saying
is
does he think that there's physical
copies of Hillary's emails that he had
and that's the only well again here's
the reason why he brings up this stuff
because he says Russia Russia Russia
here in a second and I'm gonna play it
but here's the thing that I I I can't
help but to
to surmise this and I think if and it
must be if it is true right but
he always tells on himself in these
little ways and we find this out over
time what he's actually saying here is
what I've been saying for weeks the
documents that he stole is intelligence
gathered on him it has his name on it
that's what he's terrified of and he's
projecting this idea that he has Hillary
Clinton's emails which is
I mean maybe he does have like right
questions
he goes no no I'm just saying many
people are same
right why would you I don't make no
sense like why would you well it does it
does if you do the full context here
yeah listen listen to this part about
Russia restaurants
okay and a lot of people said the only
thing that would give the kind of
severity that they showed by actually
coming in and raiding with many many
people is the Hillary Clinton field the
Russia Russia Russia stuff or I mean
there are there are a number of things
the spying on Trump's campaign so they
spy to my campaign
again I'm telling you I'm telling you
the the [ __ ] he stole from our
government is intelligence
that our government and our intelligence
agency collected on him when he was
colluding with Russia to try to steal
the [ __ ] election in 2016 by using
the Hillary Clinton email talk you
remember when he stood in front of the
microphones and said Russia if you're
listening I mean you remember this [ __ ]
right you remember this stuff this is
intelligence that they collected on him
that's the [ __ ] that he stole that's
what he stole he's a [ __ ] traitor
they know it they were collecting
evidence and Intelligence on how he was
a goddamn Russian asset they [ __ ]
knew it he knows it that's why he got
these records and packed them in the
boxes with his clothes and his pictures
and took him down to Mar-A-Lago Because
he believes that there's only one copy
of this [ __ ] and he has it and that's
why he's mad that they got it back
that's why he's Jack John yeah uh
Garrett over here says what morons look
at drump and say oh yeah that's my guy I
don't know I don't know why you'd want
me to play the whole
clip there it is
my go-to uh the Foo Fighters and but
like just the song There Goes My Hero
and like they imagine Trump walking
there like there goes my hero and it's
it is funny because you watch the clip
we and I mean the clip's even playing
behind you right now right watch you
watch the clip thinking
uh or or fake Gabe thinks that it's
actually going to benefit the argument
to say full clip more context right he's
not as dumb as he actually sounds
Hillary's emails uh FBI uh I colluded
with Russia and that's what the
information delusion they spied on my
campaign okay Russia Russia Russia
emails FBI boxes paper uh stapler you
know like it's it's one of these things
where you look at it when you're like
it's not giving full give me the full
clip fine we'll [ __ ] laugh at it all
day but it's not gonna help you no make
your argument that there's some sort of
four-dimensional Chess going on that no
one else can think about but it's really
this stable genius that is Trump
the guy is an idiot the guy stole
documents he's a criminal too by the way
yeah yeah and the guy was told on
multiple occasions don't take the
document and give them back not only not
the thing is is that most people would
have been locked up already but they
gave him way more chances way more
leeway than anyone else would get he
already had chances not to commit crimes
and skate on these crimes and that's the
other thing too about this interview
that we can't play the whole thing
because we are running out of time here
we gotta go but here's the thing is that
this interview is packed full of him and
Sean Hannity talk about more and more
crimes that he has committed and him
trying to make arguments that sound just
as dumb as I thought it so it must be
truth it's just as stupid or dumber than
the other crimes that they have to
[ __ ] talk about and how Sean Hannity
has to question him on here's what I
here's what I'll tell you um you don't
have to question uh dark Brandon on
crimes but but I will tell you if you
want want some dark random merch go to
store.doney michaels.com we got some
great dark Brandon merch over there at
store.d Tony michaels.com here's another
great picture of the exclusive Dart
brand of design the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget to go over to uh
the store.thedonymichaels.com you can
also check out the uh Rhonda Santos can
go [ __ ] himself
he can go [ __ ] himself right the campus
can go [ __ ] himself I'm pretty sure
Trump would buy a t-shirt like that if
he had money well yeah dude can go [ __ ]
himself I'm sure you know if Trump's
listening maybe he can go buy a few
shirts and pack them in those boxes with
the clients provide documents um
everyone also remember we are still on a
YouTube man but I think it's gonna get
lifted a day game so I think tomorrow
night I believe I think so we're back
yeah it's for you I mean still keep
coming to Tony tackles not live yeah
absolutely do not do not let me hide
behind the the uh do not forget to come
to uh Tony Michaels dot Live Support
Independent Media again there's there's
a tip jar there where you can tip us one
time tip or you can do it leave a
monthly tip so you can just set it and
forget it you don't have to worry about
it you can do either way anything is
appreciated but we really appreciate
your support here rather it is monetary
whether you come and watch rather gay
fake Gabe watches every single lead
watches ever he's a dedicated loyal
pushes oh my gosh let me tell you what
that algorithm loves Game Vape game he's
in there he's commenting he's responding
to people he's responding to us he's a
he's he is a loyal Watcher every single
day and I hope him and his entire family
come and listen to maybe they'll
eventually get some truth um through
their thick little skull and they'll
thinketh and they'll be us because
people are thinking gay people people
are thinking a lot of people a lot of
people are thinking and don't forget
don't don't forget to think about
tomorrow coming back here because we
have bone net of the week it's Friday
every single every single week every
single Friday second hour bone end of
the week the poll will come out tonight
go to Twitter at Tony Michaels pod
follow us there you can also uh vote on
YouTube if we can put the poll up but I
won't be able to put the poll up so go
to make sure to follow us on Twitter
right that's where the poll will be at
Tony Michael's spot if we can't get it
up on YouTube I don't know what time
this band stops but I don't know I don't
know we're still we're still on Twitch
we're still on we're going tomorrow
we're going still on Twitter we are
going all of these places just like
Facebook as well we have not left you
can download it even on all the
directories listen to it right so keep
keep going and really do us a favor and
go over to YouTube and subscribe over
there because we're gonna get this band
lifted soon and we want to have as many
people over there listening as we
possibly can when we get the band lifted
thanks for sticking with us tomorrow
same time same places maybe an extra
place maybe YouTube yeah and we'll see
uh we'll we'll put it out on Twitter if
we if we get the band lifted everybody
see you tomorrow Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon